this is it the creme de la crop of
Indians something I honestly hold on a
similar level to if you may be as it
ends just as perfectly as that series
did in my eyes we somehow made it out of
the content cave to bring you the
definitive The Last Arc of Hell's
Paradise the departure Arc the sir this
part of the series is actually like
perfect the way everything is wrapped up
leaves me feeling completely content
with it yukikaku was originally an
editor who worked under the Big G
tatsuki Fujimoto during fire punch and
due to his relationship with the boss of
Jump Plus he was able to drop this
series without holding back on anything
at all and it's evident throughout this
final Arc that man truly didn't but
before I spoil you on anything that did
happen throughout this final Arc don't
you either just get the need for a mick
jump in and wonder what am I which path
shall I follow the answer my fellow
dejin is Mick Arena's league divisions
before we even get there though Macarena
is a completely free to play game so
there's literally nothing stopping you
once you're in progress through the div
9 by playing a bunch of easy quick play
matches then once you smash that out
you'll get stacked up with a bunch more
stuff to do like 5v5s or my personal
favorites because I'm an absolute
competitor Fame league divisions
divisions are in my opinion the best
thing to like do once you get into the
game is they allow you the fastest way
to produce in Macarena when matches
Merck nerds and earn ranking points earn
enough ranking points and you'll go up a
division there are 11 divisions which
act as an initial track of game
progression each time you enter a new
division there is a reward which
progressively gets bitter going up a
division is a passive boost to General
progression as it resets XP caps on
players and points him towards unlocking
more resource crates along with extra
boosts everyone it's a completely free
to play game on Android and iOS right
now and also PC if you want to jam it on
there too and you can use my personal
link or scan my QR code to get bonuses
worth thirty dollars we're talking about
one skin one Prodigy crate and 5 000
credits help kick start your game and if
you're quick you can add me as well and
we can play some matches together so
don't wait around and don't miss out and
thank you again to Mick arena for
sponsoring this video anyway enough of
that sit back and relax as we dive into
the final part and wrap up everything
when it comes to house Paradise its
characters and the world it's situated
in kicking things back off is all of the
flowers around begin disintegrating May
and use a riha confront gufa who's
holding on to that weird pot looking
thing remember like that was where we
ended right at the end of The Last Arc
which was just a battle fist who far
lets them all know that Judaica cutting
down the Divine Barco you can sense that
not only is the Banko's Dow destroyed
but the islands as well hinting that the
land will soon meet its end the
reasoning for what zujin did as well was
explain to the humans who wouldn't have
had a clue about who want to be praised
by all of her fellow tents in use read
her comments on how she felt that gufa
didn't seem bothered At All by the fact
that the tensions are all dying but it's
told by him that death is not the end
for them every being passes from life
but the Dow will still remain even
though reversing their process is
insanely hard pretty much impossible
under normal circumstances the Little
Man reveals they have a chance of being
revived through the Basin pot looking
thing that he's holding inside of the
Basin it holds all of the Fallen
tensions of yours which after a thousand
years had passed will allow them to
fully revive use riha who like doesn't
care about what happens a thousand years
from now decides that it was time for
her and may to enter The Floodgate but
it's worn by gufa that yes she might not
care about the future but she bitter
fruit about what's going to happen in
the coming hours from now as riyan
cannot be stopped
meanwhile over at all those sneaky old
floodgates shoe can burst his way
through the overgrowth and grabs onto
the Anchor's line and an attempt to Halt
the ship's departure to Japan I don't
know like what the man was thinking and
as we probably all saw coming the line
snaps allowing riyan their safe
departure however turns out shugan
actually tore the rope in half himself
to use the anchor as a grappling Hawk to
fling himself all the way up onto the
boat standing there in front of the
final boss shooken state that he doesn't
care what cargo he intends to move but
he wouldn't even reach the mainland
looking back at him Rhian tells him the
same and that not a single soul will
leave this island alive darting at the
immortal she manages to easily defend
herself against Shogun but also tries to
hold back as to not damage the ship's
interior shooken screams at himself to
not falter and slashes Rhian across his
chest but this has no effect due to his
water down not being the right match to
hinder the creatures would dow pointing
her finger forth even shoots a blast of
Dow which connects directly with his
spot on Sugar's chest where his heart
would be sliding back or gritting his
teeth the Yamada states that they will
not fall to these dark arts of these
veins revealing that somehow for him
splice of Dao actually hit teams's
headband which he'd placed under his
robe thinking about how Tinder saved him
once more sugar notes that that Reckless
assault will only serve him poorly
instead to when he must call forth the
true essence of what it means to be a
Yamada a Simon choosing to replicate the
abilities of the other Yamada to fight
sugar bursts forth and uses a plethora
of his friend's abilities to slash at
the creature for instance there's
something strange with shugen's Dao and
upon receiving another cut towards
tandoned for a replicated attack used by
xion she starts to actually cough up
blood jumping back in fear Brienne is
just confused as she was sure the Stu's
doubt wasn't meant to affect him yet
after looking closer realizes that
shugen has the ability to change the
attribute of his Dao which they always
assumed was impossible saying that they
have to take him seriously now ran drops
the control they head over the Flames
around them to give him full attention
to her enemy during the battle shugen
who ain't really concerned with these
Flames tries to attack yet ran who would
have loved to study this man on in the
other day takes things up a notch and
Sievers sugan's rights armor they be the
fan she then states that time for
tinkerine is over and changes to their
true form as Yin allows for a far
greater Focus back over with the uh
children's size tencent may ask scuffar
as to what exactly rhian's true goal was
flashing into a dark room and using
their Dow illusion ability goofasho's
May and yusu rihao what they saw earlier
in rhian's laboratory so remember in
their Last Arc where goofard got a price
at a revelation that wasn't really
expanded on well here it's shown that
not only did he find the obvious of all
of the other tents then but also an
extensive amount of research on
restoring the body of someone not the
soul then beyond that he noticed a war
that wasn't in place behind that
unfamiliar door hidden by an illusion
was even more research and notes that
alluded to the true goal of riyan we
will think that it's the Merc every
single person inside of Japan and yes
that is true but just as everyone reacts
to these clones looking after a
mysterious crippled figure in beard May
lets them all know that that person is
the Grand Master
I said a noise then breaks him out of
the illusion as goofah explains that the
noise came from Rhian who had managed to
finally set sail on the open ocean after
having dealt with shugen despite the
circumstances may ask scruffa to
continue with the explanation on Joe
fuku's plan who far tells May that they
are making an incorrect assumption Joe
fuku had indeed died long ago and has
already been turned into a gold statue
so that his body can be preserved
undergoing other vacation back in the
past when they were first not permitted
to meet with their Master it wasn't
because he was busy more that he had
actually Amplified and passed from The
Immortal Realm for the last 700 years
riyan has worked non-stop for this day
the way of Dao explains that the soul
and body are one and through this it led
her to believe that they would have been
able to revive the soul just like any
other part of the body goofah then tells
may end user riha that rhian's true goal
is to revive Joe fuku using the Dow of
all of his citizens inside of Japan not
use it to make a perfect Elixir for
themselves like we originally thought
knowing that jifuku was already did and
while speaking in their native Chinese
tongue may ask scruffa who was the Hoku
that they found earlier on when getting
the Basin thin and in a crazy Revelation
philosophy Man reveals that the person
was the real body of Rhian who'd began
abbifying in that room the person that
they are familiar with is merely a
puppet crafted out of Dow that she
controls the puppet's insane quality is
due to the level of Doubt manipulation
that surpasses what every other tension
is capable of all of it points to one
solar conclusion in his eyes Rhian is
not even a tencent but in fact a human
and the wife of jofuku when Joe fuku
actually left ancient China with his 3
000 voyages one of them was indeed re-in
the tencen all originally thought and
were taught that they were an
amalgamation of Mystic Dao and flower
Dao yet this was false first reincreated
another version of herself and from that
the other tencent were all born back
when a change first started a show in
every end it wasn't because she was mad
but because her body had started to
undergo other vacation limiting new time
and only allowing her to control the
Clone version of herself remotely goofa
who doesn't fully understand the matters
Beyond his comprehension Jessica's
reinfolish and starts to criticizing
notion of love that humans have and his
eyes and makes them pretty and cruel
full of arrogance lacking in style
suspicious and paranoid and even still
it drives them to sacrifice absolutely
everything that they have after over a
thousand years of building everything
somehow Ren is willing to throw away
everything if it just means that they
get a chance of holding their love once
more then well the final statement he
tells them that within two hours Rhian
will 100 reach Japan to initiate their
plan taking this all in use already have
panics wanting some form of break after
everything that they've been through she
even questions if this is just another
trap that tense then they're trying to
set up for them but goofar explains that
he's stuck in a paradox of his own he
wants Rion to leave but also wants to
save her unable to understand these
feelings he currently has he asks me for
her opinion on matter but before she
could even give her answer usury are
hurts her over the head and tells her
that they should hurry to where the
others are as a Parting Gift who far
warns her that according to the eye
Chung they found in brienne's room which
for those who like forgot iching allows
the Texan to tell the fortune of
specific people through this he was able
to determine that 100 only two men and
one woman will survive goofa himself
relies on this chant before she fate and
those names who are known cannot be
included inert but rien themselves may
even be among those countered one thing
is for sure though the art of aiching
does not lie having left goofar uzuriha
and may then arrive at the entrance to
the floodgates with everyone else
gathered obviously with the exception of
gentitasai who's already gone ahead to
try and stop riyan from departing as
well as the absence of the other
brothers who have yet to return and like
they just don't actually realize that
chobe has passed on yet after discussing
how they need to find a specific ship
with a like Light low to catch the main
vessel the group into the floodgates
only to be really disappointed that all
of these ships have been burned looking
out through the wreckages nurugo spots
one unharmed ship but is told by xion
that they will not be able to use it
since the wreckages of all of the other
vessels as blocking the water from
flowing and allowing them to move out
with everyone left absolutely hopeless
Gabby Maro sees another vision of his
wife in front of him and dives into the
water to try and remove the debris
himself Jacob tries reasoning with him
but our boy screams back they're
rethinking it is impossible he only has
one goal and refuses to give up wanting
to help and seeing the pain in his eyes
both sigiri and naruga dive in to help
him despite it being an impossible task
standing behind them our little girl may
thinks back to what goofah had just
previously asked her pointing her little
hands forth and closing your eyes use
the rihar then sees Mei about to unleash
your power which she instantly objects
to doing so since she knows that her
body will be at risk she pleads with her
asking if she wanted to talk with Rian
and Angel fuku once more but with a
smile on her face May explode and
transforms into her kitchen State
commanding everyone to get on the ship
while she handles the task of making a
path which is like damn May why did you
have to go and do that I know there's
this pot thing but still may like why so
skipping back and back in the early days
while looking after the first humans who
came to the island with them may asks
Joe fuku why he decided to bring people
to the island since the emperor only
seeks The Elixir shofuku explains to her
that because Dao goes far beyond just
typical human understanding she
shouldn't concern herself with these
difficult matters pretty much saying
that it's above the level of human-like
capacity in another memory and after
Rhian finished a session of like dank
botchi juicy with Joe fuku May is told
by her to not feel ashamed by the
practice as even the young ones will
perform this training someday so she
mustn't continue to Harbor delts then as
the children Grew Older she wrote calls
to punishment for defying rien and how
she felt powerless to do anything about
her she was fed up with it all so she
fled and told herself that she was
unable to make a change but after
recalling goofah's past question as to
why why she returned to harai May
remembers that it was once again because
she was fed up with it all and the
present May explode into a kishikai
state and continues to say that she was
fed up with having fled over and over
not anymore though now she flaps all
five of her massive wings and blows away
the wreckage giving everyone a clear
enough path to get on board this shirt
security prepares herself to yell out to
me in concern but is interrupted by
Gabby Morrow who begins yelling at
himself telling her that she is at risk
of dying as she continues to stay in a
kishikai form and her original goal of
being able to live a normal life will
fade away May then returns to normal
dropping out of her fighting form and
hugs both sigiri and gabimaru
individually she thanks both of them for
everything that they have done for her
but this this is how she takes
responsibility for everything in her
life she tells the confused gebby and
security that watching them has a way of
filling her with courage and finally
thanks aguiri for combing her hair and
he passed before slapping her Palms
together revealing that they were
actually in an illusion and may had
indeed trans supported everyone to the
ship safely as May uses one last gust of
her wangs she pushes the ship forth
allowing them to rush after the final
boss in their last moments and as she
begins to fade away they apologizes to
everyone for not being there to sail off
with them to her father hoko to her
family and to Rhian for not realizing
their feelings after they banished her
and how she would have been able to stop
them originally
elsewhere and aboard the ship algae buy
the dragon to my again teacher's side
walks his way through the Flames of Hell
over the other side of that like burning
ship ran reclaims the elector of life
after finding it lying next to the
defeated Shogun she then wonders as to
why he had it on him that quickly
dismisses the question after having her
back in her hands with the uh what the
election return rein sees that all that
is left to do is put a faith in the
paradise butterflies and becomes happy
to know that her dream will soon come
true as things were going well in her
favor the puppet randomly stuck to feel
its body suffering due to rian's Dow
control starting to listen we're time
running short in her eyes Brian hopes
that she reaches Japan soon meanwhile
and over the other side of the Flaming
deck gentotsai finds shugan unconscious
and starts to wonder as to why his
favorite arm wasn't bleeding shugan then
wakes up badly injured and sees getting
hit to start standing right in front of
him without food she by his side but
soon remembers as to why this was not
the case gente's just like tells shugen
that he was glad that he managed to wake
up since it wouldn't have felt right to
cut him while he was still down somehow
though sugar manages to block the first
attack on him but falls down after being
knocked off balance losing his sword in
the process Gente decided tells Shogun
that it is useless for him to fight back
now that he has lost his right arm but
is told by the injured of Simon that is
a samurai he cannot give up just
straight up annoyed getting his decide
kicks sugar in any face and screams that
all of them are a band of fools all of
this damn honor and dignity forced him
to cut down one of his own friends he
punches him in the face and kicks him in
his stomach while telling him that his
ways of living are utterly corrupt sugar
makes in an attempt to defend himself by
swinging his sword but fails after
losing his balance once again
gentitrusai then turns us back on shugen
calls him out to be a purely pathetic
Samurai and tells him that he doesn't
care if he decides to burn to death now
as he watches the blade of a sword
burning the fire in front of him shugen
grabs it and quickly cauterizes the
stump of his right arm after remembering
Future's advice about disinfecting a
wound he practices getting used to
swinging his sword with his left arm in
front of advantageous site and recalls
the time virtually discussed with them
that the human body as a tool and that
by searching its construction and limits
one can manipulate it as they see third
genetic design then becomes shocked to
see that Shogun in a matter of moments
managed to adapt using his left arm to
wield his sword the Yamada screams to
get into desire that Fuji was caught up
in a center mentality but says that a
samurai Spirit lives on within him now
falling into another memory of the past
he recalls the time where he pointed out
how weird the Yamada Clan was Fuji
though said that even though they got
rocks thrown at them for being that like
weird group of people the clan allowed
them to partake in his offbeat
proclivities and for that reason it's
always going to be extremely dear to him
shugen then proceeds to talented society
that someone like him can never
understand a samurai sense of duty to
protect all of those that they hold dear
to them and that his long since
abandoned his own sentimentality after
he finishes his statement shugen's eyes
then mysteriously begin to invert and
change color not noticing this though
Big G points out the fact that he sheds
tears quite a lot for someone without
sentimentality and prepares to fight him
but since there's something different so
back over with the other group and
earlier on before arriving in their
floodgates shugen senses a strange
energy emitting for the gourd containing
the elixir of life becomes suspicious of
its content prompting him to straight up
open the bottle and taste test it for
any underlying poisons much of the shock
of the Shinobi accompanying him he spits
out its remains and then declares it to
be safe for consumption by the time he
faces gentechosai though it's obvious
that the full effects of The Elixir is
shown have run its course as shugen's
eyes start to change in a rapid moment
hitting darts at the elderly G and tries
to strike him down comparing him to last
time gang teachers I notices that shugen
is somehow able to fight properly as if
nothing was even wrong and that the way
he moves his body is similar to foches
to him it's as if he's fighting against
his own friend which complicated things
for him even more and meant that he
didn't even defend as the fake Fuji
sliced at his chest after his robe is
cut open ganti Desai sees the bandages
that future used to heal on worth before
his own passing and decides to stop
fighting for that reason looking at him
shooting questions if he was ready to
surrender yeah and a freaking million
years though like like I I think you
need to understand that big G and
titusai is built completely differently
he tells shugen that he was just
remembering the reasons as to why he
boarded the ship in the first place and
how he never even intended to fight him
slowly standing up now gentitis explains
that in the past he taught the provinces
fighting anyone of strength but at some
point they never even scratched the urge
he sought to find his nickname blade
Dragon came about after he took down his
very first Monster a ryokotsu known to
us feeble English readers as a ship's
kale with that said get into size Smiles
as he brings his sword down and slashes
the ship in two causing a massive
explosion as the energy blast connects
with the ocean blow falling back with
his wounds reopened he laughed as he was
unable to completely cut the ship in
half but figures that one more attempt
would be able to do the job absolutely
like enraged with what's just happened
rien floating there in the sky starts to
ask what in the world has done against
his aside their notes that like
obviously the ship couldn't even be
sliced into completely since that's
actually made it out of Dow and then as
she slowly begins to stroll towards the
duo now says that he didn't manage to
cleave the ship in two but did indeed
manage to slow her down enough for the
next crew to make it on board guessing
that his work here is finally done he
released himself to get off his shirt
instead of continuing to fight stating
that his life was indeed a gift given to
him and that now he will not throw it
away however he does tell both Rhian and
shugen that someone else stronger than
him will arrive shortly and that he
hopes that they're ready to face him
then looking over the boat and Through
the flames he becomes happy to see that
Gabby Morrow and his Squad had finally
pulled up Gabby Morrow flings himself up
on board the ship compliments gantar to
decide for the work he has done so far
and tells him that he will handle the
task of taking down his ship as he faces
both Rhian and shugan alone
so it's the final showdown now boys but
right back before boarding the ships
themselves Gabby Mario pointed out that
the Flames were probably too strong for
everyone but him to jump on board so
alone now and walking through the Flames
like a yamabushi monk Gabby Mario
approaches Rhian and Shogun shugen then
standing there himself takes note of his
sitting in front of him and Compares it
to the portrait he and Eisen looked at
depicting hell which in my eyes just
goes back to hell like this series is
called jigo karaku and how that word
when broke down means one human and two
Hells I like actually wonder if that
also refers to the amount of survivors
that this mission is going to end up
with two men and one woman could have
also been in front of our eyes from the
very gecko I just I love that like
Paradox as well everything about these
like the end of The Last Arc and this
Arc here has kind of just been paradoxes
throwing up people anyway anyway let's
push forth and discover how Yuki into
this amazing series nevertheless sugar
then announces that he will for the sake
of the world and the clan punish even
the Devil Himself hearing his war cry
can be Mara commented that he's already
used to this hellish domain while Rhian
on the other hand just found her
situation with them to be extremely
irritating in an instant all of them
then Clash blades hands and feet in a
three-way free-for-all continuing all of
them then waved through each other's
strikes Rhian blocks getting maro's
attack and tells him that she will not
allow him to damage the ship any further
and will use everything they have to
kill him or stomp any foot onto the
ninja rain sees that Shogun was about to
attack her from behind and uses her fan
to counter Helm taking things upper
level sugar manages to anticipate her
attack and uses the Dow Century ability
and comes in to strike using xion's what
Affinity however Rian who's just like in
another class when it comes to the level
of skill stands on the tip of Sugar's
sword then sitting down she tells him
that as a shin sin the highest class of
hermit a human such as himself would not
be able to harm her before raising her
hand and firing a point-blank invisible
Dow attack watching this from the side
Gabby Morris is that Rihanna is a lot
stronger than Sujin and ran but
remembers from his conversation with
chica earlier that as long as Ryan's
priority is keeping his ship intact he
should be able to hold his own and the
battle Rey and suddenly become shocked
to see that it hand and got slightly cut
and sees that it was done by no other
then our Queen sakiri who boarded the
ship after remembering that gabimara
will need her help since her Wood Dale
will actually harm me in and you know
like his alone won't actually be able to
take her down after Naruto who's like
settle on the other boat with everyone
else makes it point that their best
chance at survival is fighting together
the other survivors with the exception
of jika because just man's always on the
snake and can't be bothered doing
anything or decide to board Ryan's shirt
to take her down together reinstates
that a gathering of humans will do
nothing to stop her however Gabby
silences her nonsense he already knows
that they're just a bunch of randoms who
came together to fight but they will do
anything to survive and make it home
together knowing that rained out is too
powerful he was a reha and Gabby Mario
decided that the best course of action
is to try and have it replace all of her
energy here similar to like how they
managed to defeat ran and then with like
everyone else acting as distractions
around them so that they can keep up the
battle sprinting fourth usuryha makes
the first attack by using her nimpo
concealed armor ability in combination
with her nympho puppet slime to create
her Supreme move ninpo Crimson
confection guard she knows that only two
dudes and one chick Will Survive but
pushes forth either way and puts you
faith and sigiri and Shion knowing that
both of them can make the final cut
together Rianne will fight complete ease
destroys usurya's armored soldiers but
is struck in the head after failing to
notice the sneaky kunuichi charging
towards her even still rain manages to
Simply send her back with a down fuse
blast however in that moment she's
caught off guard by naruga who while
sliding behind them remembers xion's
teachings and the use of Dao and cuts
rhian's left arm using tenses Ito Ryu
ultimate pounding torrent technique with
his body beginning to fall to birth
Rhian quickly reconnects it and uses the
partially seated Branch arm to grab a
hold of nurugai but luckily for our
Mountain Warrior as you'll learn once
again cut off by the blade Dragon who
came swooping in Gabby Mario who like
comes down from above notices a perfect
opportunity and in combination with
gains exercise merciless eye color Sky
Peak splutter uses his sacred art Shandy
Gus to simultaneously light on fire and
cut the Immortals tandem with Rhian lift
wide open gaming Mario calls out to
sagiri and Shion to perform the combined
attack to destroy reinstanding stepping
forth then and a perfect motion both of
the Yamada use the ultimate techniques
hidden blade dual wheel motion to bisect
The Immortals top path sending it flying
into the air and bringing the intense
battle to an end
and retaliation detention simply clamps
their hands together revealing that
she's perfectly fine and the events that
had transpired were simply an illusion
of Doubt all created by her which is
actually just freaking mental look into
her left scary watches Shion fall down
in front of her well this self still
stunned rayon walks forth revealing that
everyone except for shugen Isuzu
hiramaru and Gabby has already fallen
irritated with a pathetic foolishness of
these humans she explains to sakiri that
Hermits are those who touch upon the
truths of this Divine plane the only
thing that has ever remained beyond
their reach is the world of gods
themselves still in her eyes she will
soon reach even that state revealing the
Buddha like kezuka state that she wields
All That Remains now in rheem's eyes is
the complete destruction of wagowo after
seeing Ren enter a kishikai form gaming
Mario appears to use this technique
against her yet reyen instantly blasts
him in the face with a down lightning
bolt before he is given a chance to
attack scary comes in and actually
manages to every instantly from behind
but as told by the attention that her
doubt is far too weak to harm her body
seeing that sagiri was about to be
crushed shugen jumps in to save her from
brain's down manipulation and orders
both Isuzu and kiamaru to have the
criminals return to the ship explaining
that they cannot allow a monster to
steal the Amada Clan's duty to execute
him just absolutely crazy that he's
still got like that in the back of his
mind with everything going on right here
anyway hearing that some of them were
going to like try and Escape bringing
dismantles the entirety of these ship's
exterior setting pieces of wood flying
everywhere while keeping the room which
your foku is placed intact elsewhere and
like Walt sakiri holds on to kiramaru's
hand she becomes extremely shocked to
see that the younger Simon has already
been crushed by a piece of debris that
was previously seen flying poor dude
rest in peace Keo that's uh that's one
down seen her comrade Isuzu becomes
shock and rushes towards the direction
however Rin senses her exact location
and literally takes control of isuzu's
body before ultimately crushing her in
front of shugen much to his horror
screaming for both of his friends deaths
Shogun jumps up to with the immortalers
and tries to attack Rhian in a blind fit
of rage sneaking up from behind as well
as this happened gaming Mario grabs onto
rien and sets himself Ablaze with an
intense amount of flames watch and turn
Allah megalomaniac shugen a chance to
cut off one of Ryan's arms but also as a
side effect he is caught in those Flames
as well while trying to completely
incinerate her garimaru has a sudden
memory of yui's face and ends up ceasing
his attack realizing that he'll perish
if he continues in this battle looking
at his own hand he notices that his
doubt is starting to resonate with Rhian
and because of that he falls into a
similar Dark World to their of zujin
before suddenly bursting into a bundle
of flowers and falling to the ground
obified
so back before the um Board of the ship
Jacob did you know like his thing and
made a bunch of predictions as to how
the survivors should go about fighting
but beliefs that there is absolutely no
solution here knowing that chica himself
as I've said decided to stay on this
ship as you know they've got to have
someone guarding it in the present
though jika watches the outcome on the
ship and sees that he was right on the
survivors not being able to stop ring in
he then brings out a drinking barrel and
decides to toast at the end of Humanity
on board of this skeleton vessel and
we're watching Gabby Mario start to
amplify Ren says that she knows none of
his Ambitions but hopes that he has
pleasant dreams and as she then goes to
land the finishing blow believes that
all those who are still alive currently
will die in this fire or will Loosely
will to fight as soon as they reach
Japan sitting there herself so Gary
feels that she's utterly powerless and
reflects on all of the times that she
failed to do anything against any of the
enemies she then looks at Gabby marrow
and begins to say that she gives up but
stops in the tracks after seeing just
just how bad his other vacation truly is
rising to his fate himself Shogun badly
burned from caviomaru's Flames ordered
Securus to return to the other ship so
that she could not fight in the state
she is in he looks at the reflection in
his blade and to him it's obvious that
our girl has lost your resolve after
witnessing too many of your close
friends passed away so and since she is
like literally the only airlift for the
clan apart from Jacob he's big chilling
on the boat he orders her to board the
other vessel as he cannot afford to lose
her having survived being fatally
wounded himself Shook and boldly state
that he will make Isuzu and kumaro proud
by eternally carrying out the Clan's
juicy without any doubt within himself
as she sings As shugan's Dow surging
Sagara remembers the time Shook and
congratulated her for earning the rank
and how she would bring about a change
as a woman to the Clan's male dominant
trade speaking up scary question shugen
if it's even possible for people to live
on without doubt and if they do does it
even translate to strength over the
entire time of this Mission She's Come
face to face with doubts over and over
again her doubt as well as the doubt of
the criminal's executioners and even the
tension everyone struggles in life and
doubts themselves only to struggle some
more of abandoning doubt is truly The
Way of the Samurai then like Shion she
rebukes the role and states that she
isn't one in that case with all of the
Fallen Yamada placing a hand on her back
she screams that she refuses to leave
these feelings behind and instead while
picking up her sword exclaims that to
the better end she remained full of
doubt and confusion as for that as who
she is and I'm like hell yeah that's
giving the biggest sphere of
encouragement I've actually ever had
while writing a script this is for you
guys as well reading this video
everyone's way too harsh on each other
these days and I'm way too harsh to
myself with like my pronunciation on
words or the way I say things but this
is how I grew up this is the country I'm
in it's the way I speak get used to it I
can't do anything about it it's like if
I was Indian or something you know like
in another part of the world it's just
there's only four million of us in New
Zealand so it's a very unique accent and
like I said Gary here I'm thanking
children for these words as we truly
grateful for him looking at her shugen
feels this random asking say
emitting from sagiri that's neither
Tranquility or intensity but something
else completely different Sierra herself
then looks back at Gabby Maro and asks
him in her mind if it was okay for her
to have faith skipping back any time
once passed we see Gaby marrow been
introduced to the eighth daughter of the
chief of iwiga Curry yui initially she
becomes spooked after Gabby marrow
raises his hand towards her and petsu
heard as if she's like some sort of pit
yui questions his action twitch gave me
Mario answers that like ever since that
day he'd wanted to become more open with
her revealing that now this is kind of
like a dream state that they're in
reflecting on past memories but in that
time it just didn't feel right he'd
stolen lives so he thought he'd never
qualify for a normal life yui says that
she doesn't really like understand where
he was coming from and tells gavimo that
he is still eligible to have a normal
life despite his past sins she note that
he seemed to be suffering some kind of
pain but the acts of regret and
reflection are all part of those of
atonement she asked if it was enough
that just a single person accepted him
for who he was causing Gabby to question
what she meant thinking on this Gabby
believes that it was enough and that he
should accept himself for who he is so
that he can finally be free of his
burdens and move on
and be present now scary raises a sword
above Gabby Mario's abified Body and
tells him that he must accept his
burdens while continuing to live on she
then brings her sword down and executes
the role she was initially charged with
momentarily Gabby regains Consciousness
with his body back to normal and finds
his own flower Arbor fight head in front
of him noticing that his sense of self
had finally returned scary explains that
she had to amputate the parts of his
body that were deeply rooted with vines
and used the most outlandish method of
Dao restoration by pressing his Tandon
next to hers while he stands there
impressed with her approach siguri
states that she could not see a way to
defeat the enemy but as told by Gabby
marrow that they need to keep fighting
as long as they're alive much to his
satisfaction Gabby Maro also thanks
Aguirre for leading her back towards
doubt to increase the speed of his
healing she did despo like guiding their
thoughts in his head bringing up his
wife like ATC when she went to drop the
sword down before after security jokes
about actually following through earth
like her original task like I mentioned
before Gabby Morris says that they
cannot rely on fate due to the risk of
failure that it's given them and also
readies himself to fight alongside
zagiri together
over the others Sheila and Naru guy fall
into the ocean while carrying Big G who
remains unconscious chica then tries to
bring them on board the ship as
requested by xion but falls into the
ocean as well due to being overly
intoxicated after his Earth few slips on
the drink back there before after
everyone including user riha is brought
back to the ship jika lets them know
that it would not matter if they had
saved him since he believes that rien is
utterly Unstoppable while on the other
ship Reign since his death growing from
where girbimaru and sargeria and looks
in their Direction jumping towards her
reinvents off a plethora of attacks by
them and uses a bolt of lightning as an
attack on them but Mrs segeri after Gabi
Mario pulls her out of the way over with
the others they all watch as Gabby Mario
and security fight in perfect
synchronization but narugu also points
out that they need some sort of strategy
in this fight starting forth Gabby is
handed to Gary's sword and goes into
strike Green's Tandon however chica
knows that their strategy will not work
since the enduring attribute will lose
the necessary power needed using another
strategy gamimara attempts to use Gary
as a human sword by holding her eggs and
quickly flinging her around but
dismisses the idea after it doesn't work
any light of the ridiculous tactics Reen
sees that she cannot afford to waste any
more time fighting him and must take
down Sakira using a bulked up arms now
over on the other side of the boat
shugan looks at sakiri and remembers the
time he felt worried that she was
selected for the shogun's mission he
assumed that her kindness would be a
hinderance but now in the light of
things starts to see that it doesn't
siguri remembers how Gabby Mario pointed
out to her that she lost to shija due to
giving it to anger instead of focusing
on the middle path that gives doubt its
power and in that moment accepts both
strength and weakness and doubt as that
makes her who she truly is after her
doubt is strengthened security attacks
ran with a clear mindset of knowing that
she is the spear and the linchpin that
will take Ryan down while sneaky while
our sneaky sneaker Gabby marrow is the
spy from within the shadows as after all
being a sneaky Shinobi is what he does
best bro that was so sus familiar
moments before segeri made her charge
and remembering that Ryan's true goal is
to revive tofu
tells her to remember what happens when
those extreme emotions take over it
weakens the Dow dowels held together by
Clean Discord between both yin and yang
too much sway to either side and the
power Fades so if your heart is filled
with rage and indecision then maybe they
have a chance to win in reality and as
sargeria is placating the big boss Gabby
Mario lands in the same room as the
Gilded statue of jofuku causing the
butter wannabe to start falling directly
into their trap as he charges towards
Joe fuku's curps with a tinenpo acidic
Blaze activated give me my own nose that
when Odell was disrupted sagiri will
slasher Tandon the timing has to be
perfect but as it goes to slash down on
the floor of the boat notices that there
is a post-winning brace here a flower
crown and a pair of traditional wedding
guards laid out in front of the statue
stunned heavy Mario thinks back to when
yusu riha said Ryan's true goal was to
revive her master yet after seeing
what's in front of him Gabby Mario for
the first time realizes that Rhian and
Joe fuku are indeed a married couple
beginning to falter he tries to push
himself forth as he knows that he needs
to be in perfect sync with siguri as
this is truly the last moment Messina
means death seeing his wife with a smile
on her face appearing in front of him
though and knowing the pain that had
caused someone to lose their beloved he
drops to the floor unable to follow
through with his plan unexpectedly
though The Merchant of death sir Order
66 himself shugen the G jumps out from
behind Gabby Morrow and screams that to
be a samurai means being prepared to
give up your life at any moment for Duty
as the pride of a samurai and the pride
of the Armada Clan raising up his sword
hidden vision's eyes and doing the same
free of thought till death was single
devotion towards the Embrace of death's
warm grasp he brings down his Blade with
the vision of a demonic eyes and behind
him allowing him to deal a powerful down
impute slash they're not only slices Joe
fuku's gilded statue into but the
entirety of his ship itself having
witnessed the confirmed passing of her
loved one Reigns screams in horror as
your late husband's body is destroyed
giving security the perfect opportunity
to bisect the attention and Destroy her
plant ovule so with everything lining up
for our girl she swings her own blade
forth and manages to slice The Immortal
kishika and two with the battle finally
over sigiri Gabby Maro and shugen are
singing exhausted while the upper half
of the puppet starts to disintegrate as
it falls into the ocean below
having the fate of the immortal the ship
starts to fall apart since like the only
thing keeping it together keeping it
held together once rants down after
retrieving the elixir of Life getting
our girls out to scary to grab his hand
while they make their way back to the
other ship scary wants to look out for
shuyan once she turns around and sees
that he had passed away due to over
exerting too much of his doubt in the
previous attack continues forth randomly
gebimo watches isakari suddenly receives
a massive life-threatening gaping wound
into her chest as she was caught off
guard and hit by some sort of Doubt
infused attack with Gabby mild lifting
utter shock he turns to Sea to the
culprit is rein who stands before them
with her body being partially covered in
flowers
her only desire was to ever be with her
husband and now because of that she
states that this is the end of
everything she furiously vows to give
imara that she will take away everything
from him and the other humans certainly
Gabby Mario's left hand has been crushed
by rhian's power causing him to drop to
the ground himself laying there herself
and after remembering a past lesson from
Eisen but how I cut shaku is needed when
performing sapuku scary comes up with
the idea of using hemostasis on herself
like goofar but quickly concludes that
their idea will not work and help her
recover she either remembers gufa's past
words to her on how the only thing each
side can do now is to steal more lives
from each other and Ponders if that was
truly the only recourse they could do
after seeing Gaby marrow punctured by
Ryan's branches mirugai prepares to jump
on the boat and assist him however he
grabs her and explains that her power
would never be able to stop reyan back
over with a dying Immortal and while
having gabumar suffer for his crimes Rin
remembers how he hesitated to destroy
Joe fuku's body and asks him as to why
he did so giving my answers at any
moment he was about to strike an image
of his wife appeared in his mind which
caused him to end up faltering as Rhian
thinks about her lost love gerrymar
tries to raise him with her saying that
maybe because the both of them had loved
ones they could somewhat relate having
heard these words Ryan looks back on her
loving memories with chofuku how he
ended up slowly starting to grow old and
Arbor fire while she to live very end
stayed by his side remembering the love
that she once felt and beginning to cry
herself she brings her hands together
and in one final Act decides to heal
Gabby Maro and Securus wounds
with everyone around watching this
bizarre change and like the battle where
they just I guarantee you no one saw
this one coming reinstart to finally
disintegrate turn in her body into a
bunch of beautiful flower petals and the
afterlife it said that Rhian who was
finally at PACE managed to have her soul
reunite with her husband
over on the other boat the hojika were
like mad intoxicated becomes happy with
the outcome of the battle and tells
Gabby tomorrow and security they have
faith of them all along munched her
there as well as like Xi'an nurugai and
gantage of size annoyance on the other
hand though usuryha suggests and
forgiving him since like he is the one
in charge of staring the ship back to
the mainland as they all slowly make
their way towards Edo now which is
around about an hour away according to
xion he informs everyone that he and the
rookai will not be returning and will
instead go their separate ways on a
small boat he also reminds them about
this situation with who will get the
pardon Upon returning and that's right
guys only one person is getting this
part and two men one woman it's fate you
can't break fate I tell you now but
right now like before we get to the end
of the video I'd love to actually know
who you personally think the survivors
are this to me is just like an amazing
part of the story and it wraps up
everything so beautifully it's it's like
full me to Alchemist where you're just
the last like few episodes of that it's
just I love it so much and I can't wait
to see what the anime does with it
anyway after seeing siguri depressed
about everything light that is about to
happen with all of her friends departing
and stuff who's already her tells her
that a happy ending was never going to
be possible for them and asks if an
executioner like her started to become
fond of criminals Siri wipes away the
tears and happily answers yes as after a
while she came to see them as people
dead or hard and asks if it was wrong of
her to not know what to do in this
situation yusu reihar says no and points
out that everyone else beside herself
was actually a villain which leads to
everyone having this like Helios
conversation about just how villainous
each person is after everyone ends up
pointing Gabby Mario and his wife out as
evil Gabby shocks everyone after he
laughs at the ridiculous notion of yui
being a villain having become interested
in wanting to know more about his wife
the group then sits down and asks Gabby
Mario to tell them more about her twitch
he agrees and after the conversation is
finally finished use a riha gabby Maro
gentichasai and sagiri all stand up
together to try and figure out who will
return with the elixir of life my voice
is actually giving up I don't know if
you guys can hear it it's like croaky at
some point shortly after the Shogun then
becomes informed that a ship had to
return for the island Voyage with only
two men and one woman boarding it
drumroll please
at the magistrate's office said Gary and
Chica present themselves to the Shogun
as the only two surviving asiamons to
make it out alive and are ordered by
Aoki to make the report scaring
remembers back to how chica said he will
take the initiative or make her in the
report but wonders as to how he will do
so and Chica looks completely different
now he's like mixed up a star he almost
looks like a chicken something away like
his Goody Two-Shoes Jackie right here
chica first Bowser's head and complete
gratitude for being assigned with the
mission and tells them that since shuken
has lost his life during the mission he
will be the one to make the report
chikathan presents the Deliverance of
the elixir of life and presents that the
only surviving criminal will scan Ted to
aside the blade dragon with this
tomorrow again teachesire is then
pardoned by the Shogun and now I never
before I second doubted Big G I knew
this is I knew my man was going to take
it home like the blade dragon
no way was he going to die on an island
everyone knows that he has to he has to
die in infamy you know what I mean like
that's the only way I wanted to see
against his side go out anyway before
allowing Aoki to end all matters chica
asks him about the arrangements that
were made concerning the iwaka career
Chief sneakily Aoki confirms tajika that
the iwaka great Chief was dealt with
after the letter testified that the
leader had his own Ambitions during the
mission which was viewed as treason
against the Shogun so because of that he
was taken out much till eight year and I
was sigiri shock as they show him like
they're taking out evidence and stuff I
can't really show anybody
Aoki also reports that the body of the
chief has been transformed into a tree
after they force him to test the effects
of their luxure before beheading him as
per Jake a suggestion after he probably
got back I'd imagine anyway okay then
questions if the state of the chief
could be viewed as a mortality but as
convinced by chica that the Shogun could
possibly live forever as a Divine tree
to watch over his family in exchange for
his Humanity which I think is just
hilarious like imagine being stuck as a
tree for Humanity like I would hate it
like the dread after the business what
the Shogun was finally over jika
absolutely knackered falls down and
becomes pleased that things went
according to his plan earlier on the
ship chica saw that Gabby Mario and
yuzariha had pet game to decide as the
one to receive the pardon due to his
high reputation and suggests that they
themselves actually abandoned their own
names and form a life upon separating on
boat as obviously yusu riha is just like
a random ninja that had like a few
things known about her and Gabby Mario
himself is just a name passed down
throughout iwakukure so his face
specifically isn't actually Nolan anyway
as they prepare to depart scarier
receives a goodbye hug from Nuru guy and
yells out her farewells to use a riha
who happily waves back already having
started to leave on her own vessel
looking over she then says that Gabby
Mario is the last of the part the two
they met each other's gazes and as Gabby
Mario walks by happily saves their good
buyers without even having to say a damn
word to each other and damn I love this
panel just the smiles on their faces as
like Gabby walks past sagiri there
brings a tear to my eye like when I
first read it it truly
I throw when I was writing the script
was so like sore because I was just I
always wanted to blow my eyes out it's
just so beautiful anyway in the present
gkc sagiri thinking about like all of
the others and tries to cheer her up
stating that it was fake that brought
everyone together and now all they can
do is hope that whatever path they're on
in life and will make them happy after
hearing these words scary looks up happy
for everyone with a smile as she begins
to cry
meanwhile Thoma is also revealed to have
somehow found a boat and departed Kotaku
alive but also not by himself dude is
mysteriously accompanied by an unknown
person skipping away for him for now
though after the arrangements were made
by jika with the chief being taken out
it meant that yui would obviously be all
right as well and Gabby Meyer would be
able to go back to the clan or like
leave with yui and they'd better travel
off and live happily somewhere else give
me my who had finally managed to make it
home become shocked to see his wife yui
standing atops him stairs and eagerly
runs towards her after finally being
reunited the couple then set out on
their own path in life so we finally
made it up after 126 chapters we have
made it to our boy meeting his wife
again she ain't fake she exists and
didn't have to murk Big G along the
process it's pure Bliss in my eyes right
here skipping forth in time over in her
British Hong Kong during mid-1800s a
young man sitting in a chair notices
that the men looking down do not look
like like the locals to which he is
informed by his brother that these men
are from England due to the recent War
causing chaos and Power in the area yeah
you know who it is you guys know who
this is the Bandit Brothers Tomah and
chobe Big Chill and back together Cho
bay light here in this becomes pleased
since they he believes that this is an
opportunity for him to take over the
city and declares to the Englishman that
he now rules over the underworld from
here on out just dope hairs and I love
the fact that so Toma obviously never
made it back to the mainland of Japan
and instead probably like sailed off
card and ended up on or in China and
like Hong Kong area which is quite like
a I I guess it's probably a weird goofar
win and like goofan knows a language
there and everything as well so they
wouldn't have been completely confused I
really really like that ending for him
and it doesn't like inflict with
everyone in the main land as well back
in the room though one of the Englishmen
suddenly whips out a gun and calls chobe
a freaking baby which Thomas translates
for his brother and after learning that
it was insulted chobe transforms into
his breakdown State and murks the dude
for just insulting him at the same time
and a tea house Japan's Satoshi domain
Shion gives his opinion on urugu's new
appearance saying that she was too young
to wear there but is told by her that
she refers this new look and the other
girls around her all dressed the same
Haruka is then headed on by two random
men which she found flattering but Shion
obviously Wards them off as a threat the
rugo becomes disappointed but is given a
lecture by her like pretty much dead
figure about how all the men in this
world are either beasts or thieves
they're noticing some like dirt or food
on her face begins to clean it off the
two then decide to head off together to
try and find a real guy's people and
having watched this entire thing a
random woman wonders if their father and
daughter despite not saying any
resemblance meanwhile in over with us
singer and use a riha while they're
traveling they talk about how ganti
Desai has actually opened up a dojo
dedicated towards medicine and
swordsmanship he's ripping Fuji I love
that and a flash over there and after
finishing up a patient himself gentle
size issued a challenge by a man at the
door but yells at him to silence himself
I love it just a parallel to like who he
was in the past I've got the biggest
smile on my face right now security for
theme reveals that Jake has taken over
the Yamada Clan as the next head and is
now enjoying an easy life just like he
wanted which is dope for our man after
being tasked by usuryha as to like why
she chose to travel scary answers that
it was a good way to help you polish
your blade testing skills but also says
that if you wanted to leave home for a
little while usually have figures that
her current journey is is most likely to
visit Gabby Maro but remember to pass
statement on it being a bad idea to do
so sigiri replies that she couldn't help
the urge for a little reunion so
obviously pointing out that she wanted
to go and find Gabby marrow then ask
your mate what she also decided to
accompany her towards using real answers
it's because she wants to be her
bodyguard who secretly loves her looking
over at a random woman though use a Raha
then spots yui outside her house and as
soon as the Gary sees her as well
screams at her name and surprise
standing outside their house together
the three girls all introduce each other
and begin having a chat about all of the
things that have happened with them once
they walk inside yui offers to white
Gabby Mario up to have him see them
which causes the jokes to be surprised
as gaming Mario probably didn't sleep at
all throughout the entire time on the
island apart from like the obvious
knockout and he refused to sleep when he
was told to scary also finds it hard to
believe this but states that he was no
longer the same Gabby Mario as before
all of them then roll over to check up
on gamimaro and after saying just how
out to what he is state that they
probably can't Rouse him as dudes gone
from stray cat to literal house cat
letting him be then we skip away from
Gabby for the final time of the entire
series and leave the three women as well
to have a fat yarn with each other about
everything that has happened so far time
then slowly slips forward several
centuries to where we find goofar
running an online class while living in
human society funnily like hell's
Paradise ended drain overt so this whole
online class thing hits different when
you think that for the last two years
this man was right in the series he was
probably stuck indoors doing so but
anyway Maiden enters the room to tell
kufar that jufa and dalfa have sprouted
which was a lot earlier than anticipated
the in walking off together goofan then
says that he hopes all of the others
progress just as well
well after so long it officially brings
us to the very end of Hell's paradise
and hear its departure Arc I absolutely
loved how the series ended in general
with like us getting the payoff of
actually getting to see kind of what
happens with each character in the
future you know like does May survive
does he does she eventually come back
you know what does goofar get up to and
turns out he's a teacher in the uh the
future and everything there's just so
much that I absolutely love about this
part of this story in general and just
How It Ends it's it's like for me to
Alchemist where the ending is just
brilliant in my eyes and I really hope
that you guys feel the same way about it
there isn't really anything that I found
that wasn't explained in depth that I
wanted to know about the series in
general or there wasn't like anything
that went over my head that I didn't
understand that wasn't later on
explained in this series like everything
was laid out so well and especially if
you do like on the Manga Here you get a
good amount on the back of each kind of
volume that explains little parts of the
story that weren't really you know like
added in here but one thing I do want to
also talk about with this series is just
the meaning and General that is kind of
like pushed on or you finally understand
and they last kind of few I I guess you
know chapters of the series here you get
to understand it earlier on like say
when Santa dies and how like use a riha
kind of understands herself a little bit
more and the fact that like it's not
always about herself there are other
people that she can come back and fight
for you know and I really really like
the idea of just believing in yourself
as being the you know overbearing story
it doesn't matter what kind of doubt you
have it doesn't matter what kind of like
indecision or like confusion you might
have in your life you just need to
believe in yourself and it's a really
really run home to me when I finally got
to that last part of the arc there with
sagiri and like just her just
understanding that stuff I'm not gonna
like try and Conquer this doubt of of
like mine I'm actually just gonna ride
out and roll with this indecision and
the confusion that I have inside me and
be who I am and just like that there
just really really resonated with me
like because I I feel like everyone
needs to just instead of looking online
to see you know other people who they
like aspire to be like or want to be
like you just got to believe in yourself
at the end of the day and I feel like
everyone will be able to get to where
they want to be in life if they just
focus on themselves and I hate doing all
like the preachy stuff and all that kind
of chairs but I just I just really
really like the story in general and the
fact that it wrapped up so beautifully
oh it's just brilliant but either way
I'd love to know what you guys all
thought of the departure Arc and say
like if you had any questions that
weren't answered throughout this Arc
then let me know down in the comment
section below and hopefully I'll be able
to like go down there and just give you
an understanding throughout like stuff
that maybe I didn't mention in this
video that was mentioned in the actual
story and I'll just give you an
explanation down there or just you know
head out and get the money yourself it's
honestly it's it's worth every single
penny the art inside it is actually just
stunning to start with so I'm probably
going to get a few panels of these
blowing up and I did this dope ass thing
with Photoshop where I actually take
some of the uh you might have seen it
out there on Twitter follow my Twitter
as well if you want to see some of the
uh the Photoshop changes ups that I did
with Photoshop change routes that I did
I don't even know how to say that but I
like you take the uh the panel and you
can put this panel into Photoshop now
and you can generate the entirety of the
landscape around it and it's just
amazing what I was able to do throughout
this video with that new tool on
Photoshop but again thank you to
Macarena for sponsoring this video and
make sure you go down and hit my link in
the description options so that you can
get you know all your goodies and stuff
either way for now it's been your
professional degenerate diavolo
subscribe if you are new around here to
get these action-packed videos like this
where I discuss entire series but for
now I'll catch you all in a bit bye